there were two things i wasn't going to
watch which was the dvd i made called
pcp saved my life
you've never seen that either i did i
watched that and uh and it was every bit
as bad as i thought
and then and then there was the demise
and rise thing which one did you hate
more watching
um which one did i hate more watching uh
oh god they're equally and they're
they're it's awful it's super
embarrassing
i can't do it look i'm a douche okay no
but like do you feel like it was like
healing to see
that or not at all what no i mean some
people would think that to watch
footage that's like so embarrassing
would would
you would humble you would be make you
think i never want to be like that again
yeah but i know
i know i never want to be like that
again my experience in watching the
footage
is that like oddly like when i watched
the amy winehouse documentary and i
walked out and i was like man god i want
to get
high it's triggering somehow like when i
see the drugs on camera it's like
i could taste them you know i brought
back like this and so i just don't want
any part of watching that
i love tony hawk and he's raising money
to build skate parks by selling
a limited number of these hand signed
legendary photos and there's a link in
the bio to get one
so help tony hawk build skate parks
okay buy a hand signed
freaking print yeah dude
yeah dude